hi I'm Deena and welcome to hashtag
where we use social media to dig into
global stories the hashtag bring back
our boys has caught fire after the
disappearance of three Israeli teenagers
over the weekend picking on Saturday
with about 34,000 tweets bring back our
boys which is a play off the Nigerian
hashtag bringbackourgirls started
trending shortly after the three teams
went missing while hitchhiking home
through the occupied West Bank and this
is a big deal in Israel Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu is accusing the
Palestinian group Hamas of kidnapping
the three teenagers but Hamas has denied
the accusation
despite that since Friday close to 200
Palestinians including a Palestinian
Parliament Speaker have been detained by
Israeli forces and the number seems to
be rising soldiers have also raided
several other Palestinian cities leading
to the deaths of 20 year-old Hamid a
submarine on Sunday night several
Facebook pages named bring back our boys
have popped up since their disappearance
the most popular has over 92 thousand
likes on Twitter rapper Matisyahu wrote
we will pray for you we will cry for you
until your safe return
hashtag bring back our boys even
Israel's President Shimon Peres found
time to tweet all of Israel is with the
families of Naphtali gilad and DL during
these difficult times but some on social
media have taken the hashtag to harsher
levels like this one from Zoe H stop the
electricity and the water to Gaza until
our boys will be back and possibly even
violent levels a Facebook page was
created demanding a Palestinian be
killed every hour that the three teams
remain missing and it already has over
19,000 lights but the hashtag has found
new meaning for Palestinians we've been
using the very same hashtag to bring
attention to the number of Palestinian
kids that are in Israeli jails Remy
Kennedy tweeted Palestinian children are
routinely abducted and held for days
without their parents knowing where they
think events
hashtag bring back our voice and from
Ben White remember it's not just about
hashtag bring back our boys Israeli
policies board occupy Palestinians
constitute collective punishment daily
so this hashtag only scratches the
surface of the whole israeli-palestinian
conflict but it's one that's very
important to people on all sides people
look at on how this hashtag and story
play out over the next few days and
tweet us at aj+